[Musique]
si jeudi prochain le chef de l'état
pourrait prolonger encore le confinement
en france de plus en plus de personnes
se demandent comment va se dérouler la
sortie de crise car si pour le moment la
distanciation sociale semble être la
meilleure arme contre le coc vide 19 ce
confinement ne va pas pouvoir durer
éternellement parmi les pistes
envisagées il y en a une qui fait
particulièrement débat autant dans la
classe politique que chez les citoyens
il s'agit de géolocaliser via les
téléphones portables les porteurs du coc
vide pour les signaler si dans un
premier temps le ministre de l'intérieur
christophe castaner s'était dit opposé à
de telles pratiques je fais confiance
aux français pour que nous n'ayons pas
besoin de mettre en place ces systèmes
qui atteignent la liberté individuelle
de chacun un avis sur lequel il a décidé
de revenir quelques jours plus tard je
suis convaincu que si elle permet de
lutter contre le virus et si évidemment
elle respecte nos libertés individuelles
c'est un outil qui sera retenu est
soutenu par l'ensemble des français en
chine une application intitulée alles
ipl ce code est devenu obligatoire dans
plusieurs grandes villes
une application qui classe les citoyens
en fonction de leur dangerosité
potentielle en israël c'est un autre
système qui est en place basé lui aussi
sur la géolocalisation de la population
l'application envoie des sms à
l'entourage pour prendre ses distances
avec un citoyen suspects des pratiques
qui pour beaucoup vont à l'encontre des
libertés fondamentales de l'individu une
étape vers une société de plus en plus
contrôlées et liberticide et vous êtes
vous pour ou contre le tracking par
géolocalisation des français
[Musique]
alors ça ça a été beaucoup beaucoup
décrié aujourd'hui est ce que vous êtes
plus gros comptes on l'avait vu arriver
il ya quelques semaines on avait déjà
commencé à entendre les os sera sage
pour les français atteint du coronavirus
ce que vous êtes pour ou contre moi
gerra castaldi moi je suis pour parce
que dans cette que dans ce contexte on
ne sait pas grand chose finalement il
tâtonne on sait une chose et une chose
est sûre il faut tracer est remonté au
casero qu'il faut savoir d'où vient la
personne contaminée c'est la seule façon
de savoir comment on va se protéger nous
donc effectivement c'est un peu violent
parce qu'effectivement on pense que
c'est des libertés privées mais il faut
savoir où est le virus c'est la seule
manière pour l'instant qu'on est les
autres fixons pas de bon pas de vaccin
ou pas médicaments il faut connaître les
cas et savoir où ils sont c'est la seule
solution
oui alors gilles verdez on n'entend pas
du temps c'est pas grave allez on passe
un matthieu delormeau
il faut savoir perdre en liberté pour
pouvoir se sauver
c'est très très important est évidemment
que ça se juge sur ce sujet là je ne
comprends même pas qu'il ya encore des
personnes qui hésitent cd des sujets
qu'on avait tout à l'heure encore une
fois sur la liberté sur le respect la
dénonciation ou pas là encore une fois
il va de la santé pour le moment où
toutes les conditions toutes les
situations tout ce qui tout tout ce qui
va dans le sens de pouvoir tuer ce virus
de pouvoir sauver l'économie et sauver
nos vies est une bonne décision s'ils ne
comprends pas qu'on ne puisse pas
comprendre ça qu'il ya encore des gens
qui ne débatte là dessus bien sûr oui
jean michel maire moi je suis choquée
évidemment les ceux qui sont là ne sont
pas des pestiférés haut à l'époque du
moyen-age les talibans
il sera mal elle est une clochette pour
prévenir les gens et les gens s'écartent
et là leur passage etc voilà si on fait
ça les tracés n'accostera c'est ce qui
avait le sida etc
on ne trace pas les gens comme ça les
gens sont responsables il faut à la
responsabilité
moi pas tu as et les gens ça fout non
jeanjean mise aujourd'hui
oui mais non aujourd'hui se pose une
question c'est savoir qui a été ou pas
atteints par le virus
la seule façon de pouvoir se fier à qui
il a eu ou pas c'est de pouvoir dire à
une application gelé où j'ai pas eu ces
il n'y a pas de solution c'est pas un
tracé c'est pas sais pas si c'est la
seule solution passe à alençon et
matthieu delormeau matthieu delormeau et
cyril anger j'ai entendu des choses
horribles cette semaine à propos de
cette histoire de
singh de traçage j'ai même entendu des
gens dire et pourquoi pas l'étoile
l'étoile jaune comme pendant la guerre
mais comment peut on comparer des choses
pareilles c'est horrible de dire ça de
toute manière en ce moment l'autre et
déjà les nuits quand vous faites des
courses dans la rue je sa boule rares et
où les gens s'écartent quelqu'un sait il
vous regarde pas fait pendant l'autre et
déjà l'ennemi donc faisons en forme que
l'auto soit plus d'une minute et pour ça
justement il faut le tracé moi si demain
je lai et peut-être que j'en suis
porteur j'en sais rien et bien parfait
que les gens puissent savoir justement
qu'il doit s'éloigner un petit peu moi
aussi encore une fois c'est pour que à
court terme justement il n'ya plus que
m'a dit mais de toute manière
aujourd'hui tout le monde se regarde de
travers et on va aller vers une guerre
psychologique dans une paire une guerre
tout court
donc il faut absolument neutre asin mais
je rappelle que ça a fait ça a fait ses
preuves dans tous les pays qui l'ont
utilisé gérad et manu c'est vrai qu'en
ces périodes de crise il ya deux mondes
qui vont s'affronter
c'est l'atout sécurité ou la toux
liberté et effectivement je pense qu'il
faut être tous sécurité pour pouvoir
justement préserver
à un moment donné j'espère le plus tôt
possible nos libertés individuelles
il n'ya pas se boucher le nez
jean-michel pardon sur être traqués on
est fiché non pas du tout pas de parano
comme ça au tracking n'oublie pas que
les asymptomatiques contaminés et j'en
ai c'est ça aussi le problème est le
poison de cette maladie est donc
évidemment qu'il faut qu'on vous qu'on
vous protège
en outre à 100 il n'y a pas de problème
avec ça doute maxime est double d'accord
je peux rentrer dans les théories du
complot mais je voudrais pas que cette
démarche soit utilisé pour le tractage
massive les populations et que ce soit
par conséquent une atteinte à notre
liberté
on n'est pas de simples ok mais pokemon
gauche géant du coup me 10,9 après si
c'est la seule solution pour sortir de
ce merdier
excusez-moi de cette expression ça ne me
met pas en joie non gilles verdez qu'on
n'a pas entendu maxime verdin maxime dit
n'importe quoi on est obligé de tracé on
n'a même pas à dire est ce que nos
libertés individuelles sont altérées
c'est sûr qu'elle soit un peu altérée on
essaiera de les rétablir plus tard mais
la liberté individuelle
elle s'efface au nom de la nécessité
collective même interrogation nous
n'avons pas le choix
j'attends d'avoir la ville
le téléspectateur dans un instant on va
parler de questions quesada bien entendu
mais justement c'est sophie oui en fait
il ya quelque chose que je ne comprends
pas est-ce que ce qu'ils ont fait en
chine et c'est qu'ils ont données des
tests sérologiques à tout le monde donc
aujourd'hui si on donne un test
sérologique les tests sérologiques vous
doivent arriver en trois ans d'ici une
dizaine de jours
on sait si on a une couronne à violer
sans pattes sur un test de sérologie moi
je les ai vus parce qu'il m'a déjà en
angleterre et j'ai des genres des amis
en angleterre donc en fait vous savez si
vous avez eu le corona virus vous savez
si vous l'avez contractée ou pas donc
vous savez si vous êtes immunisés ou si
vous n'êtes pas immunisé à partir du
moment où vous l'avez contractée
je ne comprends pas ce qu'on va [ __ ]
dehors ça me ment donné tu l'as tu
restes chez toi donc je vois pas non
mais la sophistique saison parisienne
lalala vous confondez un des volets les
deux choses ça c'est pas du tout le
débat vous êtes un petit peu hors sujet
mais on vous aime beaucoup
rené mais si gentil ce riche en séries
lors des phases i run et après tu vas me
donner ton exemple prenez moi je navigue
totalement différent je sais pas
peut-être que dans le sud on est fou
mais j'ai j'ai je me méfie mais je me
méfie de toutes ces grandes décisions
qui veut se poser le moment la
traçabilité au début on a fait adapté la
carte bancaire du coup aussi tout ce qu
après on a fait le télépéage pour les
autoroutes a paraphé le téléphone avec
le tpr
mais le terrain on veut mettre sa menace
comme audi sophie j'ai appris à me
garantit que ça enlève de mon téléphone
que je suis persuadé aller mais le les
gouvernants ce qui nous commande nous
sommes beaucoup plus mal et guitar
heaven ou le maître pro fort avec cette
nouvelle machine dans le téléphone toi
tu es un champion de la vie renaît
j'apprenais la vie ils nous enlèvent
leurs drones et tu penses que c'est une
manière encore de tracer les gens et de
tout savoir sur eux au contraire et que
c'est il certifié pour cissé pour la
maladie et que tout sera éradiquée parce
que je dis que c'est pas éradiqué havana
et demi de dates dans le monde
il y avait plusieurs plus de pays qui le
choque si dans deux ans on me dit voilà
rhône et il ya plus rien du tout
il ya plus de traçabilité de ce qu'on a
mis pour le corps n'avait réussi je suis
d'accord mais je n'aurais jamais comme
tient entre autres de traçabilité la
carte bleue le télépéage eu le téléphone
qu'à tous les caméras mais le rsa ça ça
ça s'apprend rené et mathieu ou et déjà
déjà juste en un mot c'est fascinant ce
pays où on veut tous sans faire
d'efforts on veut plus virus être
confiné on veut plus virus n'est pas
être tracé je vous donne un exemple mais
vraiment je vous jure sur ma vie ce que
je dis est vrai hier je parle un ami qui
est en israël et il me dit et si en
israël on a nos téléphones qui sont
tracés est on est on est on est on est
suivie en permanence
il me dit hier j'ai pris un bus comme la
ratp locale et le buste locaux étaient
arrêtés par la police
la police est monté dans le bus ils ont
pris une personne qui était dans le bus
et qu'ils avaient retracé par son
téléphone parce qu'il était malade et
ben les gens ont applaudi l'ont sorti ya
pas eu de n y rien du tout on a sorti
une personne qui était malade car à
domicile
voilà ma part nourrir on n'a pas senti
quelqu'un pour mettre en prison c'est
rien que je vous raconte vraiment une
année 2008 et melvin est vraiment par
washington
c'est vraiment commencer par les états
fédéraux nous laisse le faire désormais
l'exemple qui dit bravo
mais ce mois-là jeu que je dis moi c est
ce qu à la fin de cette maladie 10-8
deux là est ce que tu es sûr que non
plus cette traçabilité
parce que méthode qui aura numéro vous
parce que tueur en partie dans le
battait hommes qu'il faut pas f qui te
dit que tu seras plus contrasté comme
aspo nos démocraties non pardon cyril
mais voilà alors que je dire si la ilaha
illa comme et jusque mathieu fait
confiance il se dit qu'après voilà il y
aura oui on va enlever cette sociabilité
ou imam balsam un vagin
non juste aujourd'hui on est tracé de
toute façon sur tous les réseaux que ce
soit sur facebook sur twitter sur
instagram léon c'est toujours nous déjà
quel est le problème qu'ont qu'on
connaisse no no no goût pour acheter un
tapis ou qu'on sache effectivement qu'on
croit on croise quelqu'un il ya un
danger où il ya eu un danger
excuse moi c'est quand même une notion
extrêmement importante c'est ma plus
grave que qu autre chose
lassé des questions de vie ou de mort
donc effectivement il n'ya pas de mal
quel est le mal c'est là sur jean-michel
au canada on va voir la seule des
téléspectateurs dans un restaurant mais
jean-michel merde c'est pas qui a mal
c'est que ça sert absolument rien mais
oui c'est ça moi je vois pas
l'efficacité est contaminée et en dehors
de chez lui par exemple je suis désolé
c'est facile en dehors de chez lui que
les gens vont s'écarter il y aura pas un
gyrophare sur sa tête qui dit qu'il faut
s'écarter
donc les gens iront contaminer de la
même façon et sauf que quand tu es cours
des minutes et sotchi pas mal au bras de
sortir dehors pour acheter à manger etc
avec ses passes alpes holding qui
dispute un joli col et jean sébastien
michel et jean michel je crois que vous
étiez trop occupé par votre père vous
n'êtes pas du tout au courant du truc
non est ce que tu peux lui répondre dans
ce quart est pourri freine jean-michel
ses coutures à ton téléphone tu sais que
demain tu dois aller n'importe quoi dans
un proprio l'intermarché un carrefour
express que tu veux avant de rentrer
dedans tu sais par ton téléphone qu'à
une personne dedans qui est contaminé
tout ça ça permet de pas être en contact
avec de paille allait effectivement pas
de pas de ne pas être malade toi parce
que tu veux mais qu'est ce qu'elle fout
supermarché se profile taisez vous s'il
vous plaît forte mais c'est comme ça ça
marche le principe qui concède là tout
ce qu'on n'est pas là c'est le principe
de trucs là c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne
et oui c'est très efficace encore une
fois ça l'a prouvé dans d'autres pays
c'est pas comme si on essayait quelque
chose bien sûr ça a marché ailleurs glg
répondre à rené sur les libertés parce
qu'en france nous sommes peut-être le
peuple qui chérit le plus sa liberté
individuelle et moi aussi rené mais
aujourd'hui ce débat-là excuse moi il
est dépassé face à l'urgence de la
situation
moi je te le dis sincèrement même si on
est traqué plus longtemps même si on ne
repère plus longtemps même si on nous
suit dans nos déplacements plus
longtemps une fois que l'on a retiré le
truc moi c'est pas grave il faut vaincre
ce virus il faut revenu sur ma liberté
j'y suis prêt mais moi je suis pas dit
je sais pas j bada conejo nick je te dis
je te dis je suis d'accord si je sais
qu'après l'éradication totale de cette
maladie dans le mooré
là au moins 1 du millénaire mais je suis
sûr qu'on va pas continuer à me casser
parce que la laddh
s'il nous faut que jamais le poignet du
mellois et plus
jean michel guerry important et cyril
désolé je suis complètement tombé bas
qu'est ce que c'est que cette connerie
de matthieu delormeau qui dit que quand
quelqu'un sera tracé quand on rentrera
pas dans vos prises s'il ya quelqu'un tu
sais que là le corona excuse moi tu as
pas de détecteur de métaux qui dit que
le personnes là c'est ce monde et nice
et la masse arrondies et bien si ça y
est les noms portail exigent non
excusez-moi finit-on puzzle mon chéri
injuste il faut expliquer aux gens que
non seulement on va pas dire un repas
dit à l'huile elle crie hilal coronas et
on va remonter la chaîne effectivement
de deux d'affectation va ça va
c'est ce que l'individu la prestation
plus beaux qu'on va savoir qu'une
personne rencontrée une autre personne
qui effectivement est en progression
avec une personne ou avec adam g c'est
une façon de régler de co2 de
contingenter l'histoire arrête jamais ou
alors au courrier qui veut rajouter
quelque chose à suivre géraldine qui
voulait dire un truc en corée du sud ils
ont fait ça et ça a été très très très
efficace
frison que j'allais voir remonter les
chaînes voilà qui ont été croisés et je
viens sur les jours de côté et justement
mettre les gens malades et parfois les
asymptomatiques de coiffer les confiner
et donc protéger les autres
effectivement je suis d'accord avec
gilles ouais alors sopi cause vous êtes
contrôle ou non non c'est pas je suis
contre c'est simplement l'efficacité du
truc je j'ai un doute sur l'efficacité
trouve en corée du sud
géraldine ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'il
ya des tests de sérologie et que tous
les gens sortent avec des masques voilà
la véritable efficacité
je mettrai pas abattre du moment où tu
sais que tu as les coronavirus tu restes
chez dans la soirée mais sophie meinau
mjc ou pj mais pas du tout sauf une oui
et du sud au début ils ont tracé ils ont
pisté quelqu'un est infecté ils ont
remonté la chaîne où il a ses défauts ni
par les bornes wii tout le monde n'avait
pas de masque au début ils étaient comme
nous des mines et bien sûr comme ça ils
s'en sont sortis il en est exactement
critiquer la corée du sud n'est pas là
dessus alors bien sûr les mains dans
l'application d'origine ce qui me tue
moi dans ce genre de débat c'est que on
est les premiers à critiquer ces [ __ ]
de régime
l'accord est le seul à la guitare basse
leur horizon bien fait mais à la corée
labat quelques hits us open
la corée du nord là vous qu voilà le
scénario et non pas en corée du sud et
nous car j'aimerais que le régime la
corée du sud même la corée du sud il ya
une phrase ou mairie un peu les chinois
paraît que le régime chinois voulaient
qui viennent en france et bien moi je
n'ai pas de vie laissez moi être des
pays de liberté comme la fin c'est de
commencer pas à me gonfler avec jeux
traçabilité parce que y'en a choisi
d'agde qui dope pdg que le test
ils ont fait le test il est négatif
alors qu'il l'avait quand tu rigoles là
c'est parce que tu me fais rire rené
lévesque salle il y en a que était que
tester il était négatif et à la sortie
il avait le virus alors comores et la
levée des coloris cyril astier
oui les hôtes du jour d'après mais moi
je vais en parler du jour d'appeler le
jour d'après bien mais la merde que tu
as mis leurs épaules alors rené mathieu
va très bon mathieu va traiter et
patronne et il faudrait des masses
pointe en a pas c'est comme ça c'est un
fait il faudrait être testées on veut
pas de tester c'est comme ça c'est un
fait donc pour le moment pour le mans
avec le seul moyen qu'on est de
combattre ce [ __ ] de virus pardon
d'être vulgaire c'est de se confiner
préféré à traçage donc un moment donné
si vous voulez qu'on en sorte
et on en sort il va pouvoir faire en
sorte qu'on puisse vivre et que
l'économie redémarre
soit vous discutez en permanence vos
libertés et on va tous crever d'aucuns
jugeaient les mais il ya des vieux qui
leur parlent au téléphone
les rené lévy j'en étais pas qu'ils ont
été contaminés par le personnel soignant
par léger surpoids sont venus les vieux
dans tous les états mais beaucoup et ça
ne veut pas dire qu'ils sont dans les
actes
anna yeux mais je serai pardon et on
aurait pu savoir justement et empêcher
que les gens red eye dans les ehpad
infectés seraient pu être assez
évidemment que c'est important d'être
assez si on a des idées plein de choses
pas tous en même temps gilles verdez
rené c'est au moment où le contact
humain est interdit entre les gens parce
que dès qu'on contamine quelqu'un c'est
parce qu'on l'a rencontré parce qu'on a
éternué
donc là on a une astuce technologique
pour nous éviter ça pour une fois
positive ont la technologie l'iphone
seniors et et que le descriptif satala
au match on sent pas le nôtre à sagelat
aucune aucune autre utilité que de
tracer ceux qui sont debout coût énorme
et des amendes et vous êtes des enfants
jean louis jean michel maire il ya 100
parties de hockey j radio mailly j'en ai
par exemple toi tu es tu penses que tu
as eu le cornet les russes d'accord si
tu avais des traces et on aurait pu
remonter la chaîne
les quinze derniers jours voire des
trois dernières semaines des gens que tu
avais croisé évoquer les bons sons qui
peut être prévu en notamment d'un
éventuel risque de contamination jeu au
contraire
alors il y aura des big three allait
pourtant si on avait tracé la chaîne des
gens qui a côtoyé jean michel vert
depuis trois semaines je peux tenir
moi je veux tu là pendant l'enquêté la
bretonne avec le vois je veux voir dans
des surprises l'atmo bouillon va avoir
des surprises
oui sophy non mais là c'est plus du tout
la même application c'est hinder pour
jean mi c'est ça le truc
elle est superbe
oui vacciner prochains jeux des
questions à poser on n'a pas un train de
retard quand même c'est bien bossé de
géolocalisation cette piste sérieusement
envisagée par castanet et franchement on
arrive toujours après ce soit pour les
masquer que ce soit pour le trac hd des
gens franchement on est ou en france
cinquième puissance du monde en 2015 on
est en retard sur tout c'est ici et là
mais non mais ma maxime la terre mère
cette jolie création des jem et maxime
mais s'il te plaît maxime fais moi
plaisir tétouan mais oui l'or et la joie
on est tous on se kabylie oui tu veux te
fasses maxime
qu'est ce que je fais en face on va
continuer à subir on va continuer à se
les personnes âgées meurent aura
continué combien de temps lorna moyens
technologiques homéo laissez vos données
sont assez de sous mais laissez moi
tranquille
alors oui pardon à tous les airs un truc
qui réveille toi
mais bon jean-michel il dort avec
d'autres et les ehpad les ai pas et son
côté miné par les soignants qui
malheureusement en tchéthénie ville et
pétrole bah oui le virus et donc pas ya
été patrac et tu vas tu vas dans les
épaves toi moi non plus s'épanouissent à
rien à voir eh bien tu dis d'ebay john
justement parce qu'ils vont dans les
ehpad que c'était bien justement de les
traquer de savoir exactement les risques
qu'ils encourent et de la ligue
d'automne dans tel ou tel endroit soit
ne fait pas semblant d'être bête
en fait jean louis jean michel jean
michel faisait rire à chaque image 2d je
t'adore tué cynique du était cynique sur
eux sur lorsqu'on a parlé de l'afrique
tu es cynique lorsqu'on parle maintenant
des tests et tout ça enfin c'est
hallucinant tu vieillis mal mon chou y a
rien en donné il faut arrêter d'être
cynique il faut être mais aussi pour
quand même penser aussi que on peut être
responsable et que oui on peut faire des
efforts et que oui on est tous envie de
s'en sortir surtout toi et rené assez
fascinant quand même été un pays en
guerre tu saurais que l'europe ait une
guerre ces jeux cyniques ses droits
voilà il est malheureusement faut faire
avec
etc etc et vous appris ça jean michel
maire vous tenez ça nous acheter
n'importe quoi aux reporters de guerre
j'ai passé mon temps 12 wadi nous dit
moi par dix mois sur douze dans les pays
en guerre
je suis un peu comme ça qu'on se sait
musée des enfants on n'est pas en guerre
jean-michel on n'est pas en guerre
arrêtez cette phrase qui à mon sens est
très maladroite de la part de macron et
qui justifient plein de choses
maintenant on peut tout dire parce qu'on
dit on est en guerre arrêtez de dire ça
on n'est pas en guerre en guerre ses
côtés des êtres humains contre des êtres
humains
on est tous tous ensemble contre quelque
chose qu'on ne maîtrise pas et qui
n'existe pas et pas la même chose alors
on va voir on va voir tout de suite le
résultat qu'on pense les téléspectateurs
15 lorsque l'affairé que c'était très
très chaud à ce débat s'il vous plaît
pour chaque compte 50 c'est incroyable
c'est la première fois 50 50 qui a
quelque chose à ajouter
là tu là dessus s'il vous plaît alors
gilles je crois grogner sur nos libertés
individuelles pour se sauver sa peau il
est un slogan national jacques zimmer
donc tous ceux qui sont contre ce sont
pour moi des citoyens aujourd'hui
rétrograde qui n'aime pas ses larmes et
franchement bravo gilles moindrot
généraux est ce que je sentais quelque
chose juste simplement oui je reçois les
tranchées mcferrin non mais je suis bref
je suis brève
je repense à la scène qu'a raconté
mathieu dans le bus en israël
alors est ce que tu penses véritablement
mathieu que toutes les scènes vont se
passer comme ça que rappaz des scènes
d'émeutes qui aura pas des scènes où les
gens vont souvent amenés comme des
parias ou que tu penses que brown ont
véritablement ça va très bien se passer
dans le calme et le civis taxi je pense
que votre espace de confinement se passe
bien d'ailleurs vous il sait qu on ne
tentera aussi terrifiant oui c'est pas
des conséquences irréversibles genre met
des mois dans les halls d'immeubles des
aides soignants pour les dégager
un message que ça se passe super bien
reçu sur fond de relation les gens se
crache à la gueule dans la rue il se
passe bien dans leur dans l'ensemble
après c'est sûr qu'il caille jolie
sophie syrie où il ya des cahiers donné
que l'admr tournage mais là et bien
alors on en reparlera numérique bah oui
oui mais alors que l'installation vous
écoute sophie cost ont fait rien alors
on fait rien mais moi les fictions
séries de 6,6 sophie koch si on vous
écoute on l'est on fait rien on laisse
le cas est donc là c'est n'importe quoi
ce qu'on va dire toujours géré le
contraire
je me donne je peux répondre mais je
peux répondre à des annonces d'hier sa
scierie non parce que ce qu'on va faire
c'est exactement la procédure que la
france doit mettre en place
aujourd'hui c'est à dire les tests
sérologiques d'une part et le
déconfinement contrôle alors et tu as de
quoi ça fait des mois qu'elle dit la
même chose
oui chérie j'ai moi c'est fini
j'aime beaucoup mais là vous répétez là
vous êtes à côté du sujet ou vrai chez
n'importe quoi m'attendre je termine en
une seconde la main c'est pour dire que
le timon et politique aux yeux regarde
le taux d'accès petit bide
d'acceptabilité des français justement
face au confinement et son tour rend
compte que les français acceptent
vraiment la situation
c'est très très dur mais c'est faux at
il là et je la formidable les français
je vais le dire ouais parce que
franchement subira un grand coup de
chapeau à tous ces français est-ce que
je vous le dis ce match je pensais à ça
aujourd'hui
mine de rien à plein de gens qui sont à
à 4 à 5 dans des 40 ans d'échecs entre
matière et qui sont confinés
quand même pas un petit battrons avec
pas là pour prendre un peu l'air et
c'est normal c'est la majorité des
français et on pense à eux ils disent
rien il se rêve il faut trouver chez eux
il faut venir ici c'est les enfants ils
essaient de les amuser il est trouvé des
activités et font le boulot des endroits
et pour le il faudra les fesses vous dit
même si on le dit pas assez
parce que quand on voit mine de rien des
reportages sur wii on a mis un mot et
oui on a fait ça et oui il ya des gens
dehors
or en scène fanny oui c'est ça c'est ça
c'est ça c'est vraiment que je vous le
dis c'est pas la majorité c'est une
minorité mais moi j'en ai marre aussi
qu'on voit aussi en compte les minorités
voilà qui sont et qui voilà qu'ils
foutent journée alors que la majorité
voilà il ya 95% des gens qui sont en
souffrance qui sont chez eux qui disent
ne rien et qui jouait à cache cache sa
béquille sont des 50 mètres carrés et
ses sourires hijab étions trois quatre
enfants et il faut vous dire est qu'ils
disent est bon on fait ce que nous a dit
le gouvernement
ils nous ont dit de rester chez nous ont
fait ce qu'ils nous ont dit et on
souffre et on dit rien et on attend que
ça aille mieux
voilà ce que vous dites est question
mine de rien aussi en angoisse de la
praye parce qu'ils disent comment je
vais faire avec mon travail chez eux ont
peut-être que mon patron
il va faire faillite parce que l'on
travaille pas de +23 de de trois
semaines voilà et et franchement est ce
à moi ces gens là je leur tire un grand
coup de chapeau
voilà je voulais vous dire non et ça on
les passait tous les français sont
exceptionnelles dans cette situation
voilà moi ce que je vois sur les réseaux
ce que j'entends
voilà je vois des gens qui sont copains
avec leurs voisins qui font potes qui
sont créés il ya je vous le dis moi
quand je vous entends quand j'entends
certains d'entre vous abbas est pas là
heureusement la majorité d'accord et pas
mais quand j'entends certains rouges
l'impression que c'est la guerre au
contraire moi ce que je ressens en
france en ce moment c'est une solidarité
je peux vous dire et je trouve que la
plupart des gens ils sont extrêmement
docile et il respecte le confinement il
respecte ce qu'on leur demande
et mine de rien je vous dis pour des
gens c'est très très compliqué rester
dans 530 me dans 1 40 mètre carré avec
cabourg avec pour quatre enfants sinon
vous dire et en ayant l angoisse ne pas
savoir ce que vous allez faire plus tard
et de se dire peut-être que j'aurai plus
de boulot je peux vous dire qu'on en
reparlera